I'm out of town at a friend's wedding
right now so I can't do a whole video on
the new Mortal Kombat trailer that drop
at a trailer for the new Mortal Kombat
game titled Mortal Kombat 1 just came
out which canonically takes place after
11 and the whole universe has been reset
and a world of constants of variables
you see the familiar phases
um in the trailer there's talk about
um you can be enemies or friends it's
your choice I'm hoping something like
Conquest mode comes back because I loved
Conquest mode Mortal Kombat deception I
wanted to see it make returns I'm hoping
we get something like that but the
fatalities look brutal and I can't wait